hello everybody welcome to this talk
about micro Python micro Python is a
snake that fits into small places
particularly specifically
microcontrollers and we're going to be
talking about that today my name is
Sebastian I'm a chemical engineer
actually so I don't have a computer
science background or electrical
engineering background yet I'm still
able to make these things and a couple
of years ago I don't think I would have
been able to do it or if I was able to
do it it would take more time than I
would be willing to spend I think I work
as a senior consultant at web step and I
co-founded a company that deals with
parsing technical drawings from for
example oil and gas platforms to get
information from PDF drawings now the
agenda for today is we're going to be
talking about the language itself we're
gonna have a look at some specific
microcontrollers that you can use to run
run micro Python we're gonna actually if
everything works well we're gonna be
flashing a microcontroller here and
getting up and running so that you can
see for yourself how easy it is we're
going to be trying to interact with
these things here if the demo gods are
willing and if there's time we'll be
talking about how you can optimize your
code so up again up until recently
fairly recently humans were mediators
between the digital digital realm and
the physical space so I would sit on my
computer I would talk to another person
that sits on his computer and we would
communicate or I would buy something
online but humans were the ones that
acted in the physical space so this is
changing now with IOT it's almost like
an intrusion of the digital
cyberspace into the physical realm here
and this could be a very good thing or
it could be a not-so-good thing and in
my opinion the one thing that unites us
all if you're a web developer a back-end
developer and that a developer is that
we helped to create reality so we take
part in this so that's just food for
thought
now micro micro Python was created by an
Australian physicist his name is Damien
George he came up with it during his
time in Cambridge I think it was backed
by a Kickstarter campaign they developed
the Pi board which you can see here the
language is under MIT license it runs on
the minimum in implementation runs on
128 case of rum and eight cases of ROM
you could get it down to four case of
ROM but you wouldn't be able to do many
meaningful things with it it it
implements the Python 3 4 version most
of the standard library is already been
written in micro Python either
completely rewritten or ported it also
has some modules for dealing with the
hardware so you see the pins there so
there is a modules to getting
information in and out of the pins this
is the logo of the European Space Agency
I think it's called
they're now funding micro Python so
Damon George I think is getting funding
to develop micro Python for their use
cases and they've been so kind as to say
that any progress that they have is
going to be go back into this general in
open implementation of micro Python
anyone from the UK I think would
recognize this machine this is called
the BBC micro and in every school
in the 1980s there was one of these
machines
it's an 8-bit computer it's part of the
the UK some computer literacy project
going in 1980s and it was accompanied by
a television program called the computer
program which ran on BBC two in 1982
teaching people how to use this now
recently the UK government has said that
we would like to provide every
schoolchildren every 12 year old in the
UK with their own small micro and micro
controller this is the micro bit
they have shipped this device to over
5,000 schools hundreds of private
schools as well and it runs micro Python
on it
so the general next generation is going
to be learning how to deal with embedded
programming through micro Python so it's
already a pretty big deal
micro Python comes in many different
ports distribution the pi board has its
own port you also have other ports such
as the esp8266 ESP 32 Adafruit came up
with its own flavour of micro Python
that they call circuit Python and it's
easier to interact with their products
that way but they're all fairly similar
the standard library for micro Python is
a little bit different from regular C
Python is in that the they're
individually installed so if you want to
use one model module you install that
module because in order to reduce size
of the firmware how it comes about it's
either written from scratch or it's
ported from C Python or another
distribution or implementation of Python
and some modules are just dummy modules
not implemented yet I guess they just
raise our not implement there or
something
here are some examples so you get a lot
of things included when you start up so
let's look at the microcontrollers
here's a list of the microcontrollers
some of them might be familiar to you
first a PI board
it runs on a one hundred and sixty eight
megahertz cortex m4 it has 192 Kay's of
RAM and this is the reference hardware
for micro Python I haven't used it
myself but I hear it's pretty good
there's a this is version 1.1 so a
version 2 is being developed is I think
it's going to be ready soon this is a
company called PI comm they focus more
on the connectivity of their devices
what's picture there is the low pi it
has Wi-Fi Bluetooth and Laura antenna I
think the more recent ones run on ESP 32
they also have a product called Phi Pi
which has all the connectivity listed
below it has Wi-Fi Bluetooth dual mode
meaning regular and low-energy and as
Laura sig Fox and also LTE em I think
cellular connectivity now this one is
interesting this is the esp8266 and it
was created by a Chinese manufacturer
called expressive as passive systems and
it was originally intended to be a Wi-Fi
module for your Arduino device so people
would buy this so that their Arduino is
connected through Wi-Fi but some people
figured out that this thing is many
times more powerful than the Arduino
itself so people just ended up buying
this and they didn't need it or do we
know anymore it's very cheap so this
thing costs you maybe 3 or 4 dollars not
this one in particular this is the
Adafruit one it's more expensive but you
can get very cheap yes
80 to 66 and they come in vert a
multitude of different types now the
next generation of microcontrollers from
your espresso is called the ESP
thirty-two now we're really talking now
really getting in it's getting
interesting
this has a microprocessor a dual-core
240 megahertz it has four megabytes of
flash it has Wi-Fi and Bluetooth which
the esp8266 did not have Bluetooth and
it has a ton of i/o pins and we're going
to be looking at that particular
microcontroller in the demo so this is
the pin out one interesting feature is
that it has a lot of touch pins so you
can use it directly for as a touch
sensor and to put in things into
perspective the SP 32 has a dry stone
MIPS rating of 600 mix and this is just
a performance metric and I think one
MIPS is the computing power of the VAX
11 780 which was huge I think was
created in 1977 so 600 of these can now
fit into your pocket this is a table
summarizing the specs of the different
hardware's that we looked at so you can
see this one has a 1/2 kilobyte of RAM
some of them actually is shipped with 4
megabytes of RAM now let us connect the
device to see if it works
see ya
this work so here you have an ESP 32
this one you need to solder the pins
yourself but you can buy ones that are
already have the pins so it has an OLED
screen very nice one and it boots up
like this so this just came from the
manufacturer so let me remove this one
we're gonna be trying to flash it in the
presentation so what you need to get
started is you pip install ESP tool
which is a Python package and we're
gonna try to let's see if we are on the
right port here let's try it so the
first thing you need to do is erase the
flash
[Music]
you must be zero let's try that
and you know what let's try a different
one because I with Linux it's good to
map the support so I made a symlink
because this can be USB zero USB 1 USB
anything so I think this one is mapped
to 2 micro Python symlink so we don't
have to deal with that that's why
okay
so we're now erasing the flash and we
use this since that I had a backup and I
think it's completed what we're gonna do
now is that we're going to use ESP tool
to to write some firmware that's already
been compiled you can decide to compile
your own port but they they you can also
just download it so now it's writing
micro Python on an ESP 32 and while this
is going let's look into serial port
communication how many of you know what
you are it is yeah so you are it is a
hardware device where so it takes a bit
stream of 0 1 0 1 and converts it into
bytes to and from it's asynchronous it's
Universal asynchronous receiver
transmitter so you need to make sure
that your laptop and your device is
speaking is communicating at the same
bits per second or else you're just
going to get garble the tools that you
can use to connect through you to the
UART is screen if you're on Linux party
maybe if you're on Windows I use Piko
comm there's yet another terminal if you
want to write Python code that talks to
this thing you can use a package called
PI serial and there's also Jupiter
notebook is what you're looking at right
now and you can run micro Python code
directly from your notebook in this case
from your presentation it's very alpha
so I've been very lucky as of yet so it
looks like it's now it now has micro
Python on it if you would like to
transfer files to this thing micro
Python has a file system you can use n
PI so you install it with pip install
Adafruit Empire and this is an example
of how you put
file into the into the microcontroller
boot up i we can look so what we're
doing now is we're just running command
line here so we're trying to look at an
pi and you have some commands that you
can do you can get a file from the board
list files so let's try to list a file
so we see that this thing huh now has
boot pi so on micro Python if you put a
file called boot PI this is the this is
the code that will execute during a boot
up so that's when you power cycle the
thing when you do a hard reset or when
it awakes from deep sleep I haven't done
this yet but it just came out
support for DSP 32 is that you have the
Webber Apple so you now if you connect
this to Wi-Fi set it up you can leave
this in your box in your device and you
connect can connect to it through Wi-Fi
so you just open your browser connect to
the thing use your password if you set
one and from there you can write code
interactively in the repple and you can
also send and get files very easily so
about the Ruppel now that we're in let's
change the kernel to micro python
first I'd like to see if it actually is
connected print one its evaluated inside
of the microcontroller so it returns one
so now we're in rebel if you write help
it provides you with some ways to get
started if you write help modules you
get a list of the supported modules that
you can just import immediately
it supports auto and then indenting so
if you write the DEF function and then
it automatically indents for you
Auto completion so you can I don't know
if that works here in Jupiter but you
can do import JSON and then write json
dot tab and then it gives you the
options if you want to interrupt you can
use control C it has a paste model
available which is very useful you
started with control e do your pasting
and finish with control D and lastly a
bit pocket variable is that if you
evaluate to something then you can get
that thing that you just evaluate it by
using this thing here I don't know if
that works here but no so moving on ESP
now we're on an ESP 32 so we can look
get the flash size in bytes available
flash size I mentioned the reset soft
and hard reset the soft reset clears the
state of the micro Python virtual
machine but leaves the hardware
peripherals unaffected so you can either
do a control D to do a soft reset in the
ruffle or write this code here this is
the same as exiting the program if you
want to do a hard reset you do import
machine machine dot reset that's the
same should be the same as unplugging
and plugging this back in
yeah so we mentioned boot-up I main dot
pi is your program so boota boota pi you
maybe you want to set up how you connect
to the Wi-Fi if it's available you do
the configuring and then you set up main
dot pi which you can change and your
boot that PI will still be relevant
right the code that you have in there so
if we have a look this is regular Python
code we're going to open the boot up PI
and read and we're gonna get what's in
the file so this is just I think it
ships with that to get you started so
this is how easy it is to set up the web
rebel ok let's move on to machine so the
machine module is how you interact with
all the pins on your device it has a lot
of things and we're going to get go
through a couple of them it has a real
time clock module we're running this now
day time it gives you the day time in a
tuple you can connect to Wi-Fi ESP at 32
supports to set up your device as an
access point which would mean you didn't
wouldn't need a router at all and they
would still be able to communicate and
the second cell is how you connect to
the Wi-Fi so we can try doing that so
what it's doing is that it's it's
getting the client oh it's activating
and connecting to an DC with an empty
password and then it's looping until
it's connected
so now that we've done this stuff let's
see if we can get something to work now
this thing is something I made with a
friend it's a box that it's laser-cut
and I tried to to make sure that all the
available pins on the SP 32 were used so
it has a joystick which is a it's
basically two potentiometers so it has
variable resistance in the x-axis and
y-axis so there you have two inputs to
the microcontroller it has a push push
button it has a rotary encoder that you
can rotate and push as well it has two
buttons a microphone and an OLED screen
and if we're lucky it's still working so
I'm gonna disconnect this now and I'm
gonna see if I'm connected oh and also I
also had micro SD and so you can mount
an S micro SD card so let's see if it
works
Oh
and we try to connect again
then we hold our breaths and it works
that's great okay I think I will also
bring this back how do I do that
I can maybe just show it when it's
relevant so let's get rid of that one so
we have two push buttons here so how do
we communicate with these guys we import
from machine a class called pin and then
we create a button which uses pin number
13 we specify that it's an input pin and
that it has that we activate the pull-up
resistor so a pull-up resistor is an
internal resistor on the microcontroller
that makes sure that when there's no
connection when you kind of when the
button is opens up the circuit that it
kind of makes sure that the voltage is
not floating around it's set at either 0
or 1 so let's try to print the button
dot value so as I click you see that
button value changes so that's great you
could do this from time import sleep
infinite loop and then print the button
dot value but I don't know how to
interrupt from from Jupiter here so
we're just going to skip that one and
talk about interrupt handlers so
interrupt handlers is something that
interrupts your running code and you and
it runs a callback function that you
define and it's and can be very helpful
but try to use it if not sparingly then
the amount of code in your interrupt
handler should be very minimal it should
only do the things that you need to do
acting on the signal change so an
interrupt handler in this case we're
gonna write a callback called interrupt
we're gone
set an interrupt handler to the button
which triggers on a falling pin so you
can trigger on either the button being
pressed or it being released and handler
is interrupts so again I think I'm not
sure if we'll see the output but what's
gonna happen then is that when you click
the button it's gonna say print out
button clicked so here you can do
behavior based on events like that you
also have a timer so you can have a
periodic timer doing interrupts on your
code which is very nice make sure so the
thing with interruption interruption
handlers is that this actually
interrupts your running code if you are
allocating in your main code allocating
objects on to the heap then it's really
bad if the code is interrupted and then
you create a Python object inside of the
interrupt handler so this is just not
allowed you you're not able to do it so
an exception is a Python objects the
text inside an exception is a Python
object so you're gonna have to run this
code you're gonna have to allocate
memory for your exception message if you
want your exception message to to be
meaningful if something happens in your
interrupt handler so now let's look at
the hardware so this is an OLED display
I got it from China it's not very
expensive
it runs on SPI and SPI is a
communication protocol is one of two you
have the SPI and the i2c and they both
run on the same pins on the
microcontroller it's called MOSI miso
and SEK so what you have is you have on
the SPI you have data going out you have
data coming in and then you have a
so this is synchronous you have a clock
that so that the devices know it can can
synchronize with each other it has a
master/slave relationship so you see the
the FID the box to the left is your
microcontroller and it has a SS at the
bottom that's the slave select so you
just act it you just specify a slave
select pin on each of your components
that you're supported that you want to
communicate through spi so that the
component knows oh it's me you're
talking to so that means that you can
connect a lot of components on a single
microcontrollers that this has SPI on
the OLED screen and also on the micro
USB I to see is a little bit different
you don't need as many pins you don't
need to use as many pins you don't have
the slave select 10 for every component
however it's a little bit slower and a
little warning the Arduino
microcontrollers they don't have an
internal pull-up resistors resistor but
the other ones do so if it doesn't work
your SPI thing on on a Adafruit device
that might be something you need to look
into so what we do is that we import
from machine pin and SPI and ADC is it
being used I don't think it's being used
so so we make a function where we set up
the display we have a function where we
clean up the display and then we run
this and now we can see that if we can
use the display so we're gonna fill a
rectangle on position XY 0 0 with height
and the color so I have to run it and
then
so a yellow rectangle so this is not a
lot of color code are you guys able to
see it but if I put up put it here cool
now we can go take it one step further
we can try to display text did it work
yeah it's small but you can see it so
the opportunities are opening up now for
what you can do now let's use the
joystick in conjunction with the screen
the joystick as I mentioned is a
potentiometer so the voltage coming into
the pin gets a higher or lower depending
on the position of the stick and it
works in two axes so then you need to
use the ADC which is analog to digital
conversion so some of your pins might
have this and you set the attenuation
level which is the range of the voltage
that you want to read and the bit size
which is how many bits you want to
divide it into the resolution so here we
for machine import ADC now which we're
going to need we're gonna specify a
button so this is the switch button
we're gonna use it to interrupt ad CL is
the left and the right it should be
maybe X Y so we're going to set up these
and then we're going to run a loop where
if we click the button then we display
clear to the display and break out of
the loop if not we're going to yeah
let's just see what happens we specify
coordinates we clear the screen and then
we fill it with a circle so
so now you can control a little dot on
your display and we kind of almost made
a game and then we click and then it
goes goes away huh there's a microphone
here and the microphone is situated
below the screen it's all of these
components are very cheap I just have to
mention so if you just go and buy stuff
you can put them together in interesting
ways and make cool stuff so we're just
going to stand see it it this is energy
as well and analog to digital conversion
so there's an analogue sound signal
we're converting into digital and now
let's just read a value 1263 that
doesn't mean much to us so let's do
something else let's clear the display
the same thing you break if the button
is pressed and then we're gonna get the
value from the mic and then we're going
to display it in the on the screen and
this is much more complicated than it
needed to be but I didn't have much time
so there's a try except to pair by the
way this is Python so you can do try and
accept then you can catch exceptions and
finally is you make sure to execute this
code no matter what if it raises an
exception or not so we're going to
display and do a garbage collect so if I
can multitask
any excuse to play music I guess so yeah
that worked there's a rotary encoder I'm
not going to get into how it works
because of time constraints there's a
lot of code here this might not be
interesting for you to look and parse
through the code for every single time
so let's just run it see what it does
and oh I forgot to abort there you go
and let's try to run it again and maybe
it wasn't good that I try to run it
again but let's try
it's not surprising that something went
wrong
oh it says transfer on D initialized spi
so this would happen once in a while I
would just have to reboot it
yeah so we're really pushing our luck
with the number of simply the number of
devices that we have here but it's worth
a shot the rotary encoder if we're going
to do that we're going to have to set up
the display again so we set up the
display and then there should be we need
to set up the switch button what do we
do that here
so we might just want to move on I guess
so there are those and the rotary
encoder yep
so the rotary encoder here we are it's
too bright so we're rotating it and as
you rotate we have a list of colors and
you cycle through the colors and then we
make a polygon where the number of sides
is proportional to the index in the list
so that's a lot of fun
okay so let's do something a little bit
more serious that we can use so we're
going to try to mount the at micro SD
this is how you do that import OS import
SD card SD card is an included driver
and micro Python you specify the pins
that is connected to since it's an SPI
device use the same pants and you mount
and from here you can print OS dot
Lister
so do you see what you have here now all
of a sudden we have a folder called SD
here so this is a 16 gigabyte memory
card which has nothing in it so let's
create a file we're gonna open test file
right and right hello NDC and now we're
gonna look what we have we have a test
file and yeah that's hello embassy in it
presumably so that was the
microcontroller we have 23 minutes left
so I think before we do that if we have
time let's go into the theoretical again
maybe we don't want to have too much fun
so with a microcontroller there might be
some size constraints depending on which
one you use ESP 32 is very powerful
you might what use some saw ones so with
the flash when we're talking about the
flash parts of the flash might not be
available as a file system that's
depending on your on your component
controller that you're using as platform
dependent so what you can do then is
that you can compile the micro Python
yourself to the port and then you can
just include in a folder I thing is
called modules included and you can also
include in a that's for frozen modules
if you want to have frozen bytecode you
there's a folder called scripts so what
this does is that it stores the pipe it
compile
the Python code and then flashes it with
the firmware so this enables you to put
modules into this place where you
weren't initially able to have it
because you can't have a file system
using that memory the difference here is
that one free compiles it to byte code
which is so you basically get an MPI Y
file and py file and you can use that
you can send it back and from if you do
is frozen by code it actually goes into
the firmware so it becomes part of the
firmware these are the steps you can
look into those maybe later when it
comes to ROM we divide we split it
between compilation and execution so
with compilation what happens when you
import a module when you're running and
running on this thing with your Apple
and you do import OS there's a compiler
inside a micro Python that compiles this
text into a compiled file MPI file and
this takes up RAM so if you want to do
that you're gonna have to spend Ram
doing so and if you instantiate objects
especially if your module that you're
importing instantiate objects that then
this also goes into the RAM so the
compiler itself requires Ram when it
compiles so this might give you a memory
error so you want to limit model module
imports don't import modules you don't
need avoid running code on imports so
encapsulate your code running code in a
function initial ation for a
neutralization function or something in
the execution phase what you can do is
you can define constant types so what
that does is that as it compiles its
substituting the reference to the value
that is putting in the actual
itself and this helps to save some RAM
and this works for any value that has
numerical that can be represented with a
numeric value in the byte code the same
thing with if you have a lot of data
like constant data or a file stream or
something you can actually compile that
us frozen byte code and you can actually
run it directly or we've read it
directly from flash which is nice so
here you have in this first case you're
actually yeah this one so here actually
you specify two strings in during
runtime and the third string that does
the concatenation so if you do this
instead the compiler is actually just
going to turn it into byte code so
there's a second thing that we have here
a device and this is the mobile
breadboard thanks a lot to my friend
Mandela for helping me setting this
thing up for NDC and let's explain what
it is we have an ESP 32 microcontroller
a lowland light these are maybe 70 Kuna
$10 it has a little LED inside of here
that you can turn on and off that has a
matrix display it has a humidity and
temperature sensor that you can buy and
two pairs of buzzers so let's first look
at the love matrix how you use that
and are we connected to this print one
helps
to power cycle again or reset
yeah let's see maybe we can connect it
through the regular ripple that looks
like it works so let's just do that
instead we can cut paste the code so
this led matrix has four by they have
eight by eight let's and there are four
of them in series and you buy them like
this so it connects through SPI again
you just sometimes you have to look into
the BA the baud rate and but the me so
and my mo C and a clock pin are usually
the same for your breadboard so just
learn how to how your bread
sorry how your marking controller works
your dev board and it should be fine so
then we set up some someone made this
module and 10:17 is the slave select n
so we do the paste mode we put it in and
oh it's working I think so what you can
do with this one is that you can set the
brightness you can fill it empty it and
then you can display text
[Music]
so what we did now is that you can't
choose the font but you can say I want
one two three four and it's going to
display it so you don't have to specify
or this pixel goes here it goes there I
think this is the offset for each for
each unit of 8x8 in x and y so let's do
something else let's open a file which
should be in the file system now called
LED text back dot txt and we're going to
read each line and put in the text
that's in the file display it on the
thing and wait a second for each between
each line so
so you can see where this is going right
we have a temperature humidity device it
works on one wire interface but the new
ones have I to see this actually comes
built in with micro Python import tht is
that simple import machine so you can
initialize a pin so this one is running
on pin 4 so you do that now it's
initialized and you measure you do deep
measure and from there you the D gets a
temperature and has a temperature and
humidity method which returns the float
values so it's 22 and a half degrees and
26 percent humidity might be a little
bit more humid up here than down there
so let's take that that data and display
it on the LC the matrix display so you
can see it's 23 degrees this one is
connected to Wi-Fi if you want so you
can display other things as well oh yeah
this thing moves so I bought a little
toy thing which has two tracks just an
engine and if you apply a current or
voltage it's six volts then it goes
forward so let's try to do that we
specify the pins just let's just do the
two left first and then the two let's
turn on first
oh did I turn it on
maybe yeah this happens sometimes it's
not entirely demo proof so the idea is
that you can turn this thing on and off
but you can also use something else
which is called pulse width modulation
and what that entails is that instead of
just having binary on and off you can go
on and off on and off really fast and to
the engine it would almost be like the
signal is weaker so using pulse width
modulation you can actually give it a
range so the motor is not on and off
anymore now it goes 50% speed 30% speed
so what you do there is that you Fred
specify the frequency I use 50 Hertz
like 50 on and off a second and then the
duty you can look at it as like a duty
goes from 0% then it's just off to 50%
then it goes on for 50% of the cycle and
then off or 100% then it's all on so it
goes from very low at a zero to full so
this just shows how you can imitate this
high or low signal by by changing the
duty the percentage so
it's true oh I wasn't connected in time
okay so if we try that if it works if it
doesn't go crazy on us we're now
instantiating the PBM we import pvm from
machine so it's it's from machine that
we import everything we instantiate the
PBM on a pin for left and for right and
those are the tracks and the anti
psyllid is the light inside of there I
don't think we're gonna use it and then
on this PWM object that you have you can
do to left duty and it returns the duty
that it's on it's zero and then you can
go let's try three hundred it goes
since it's a 12 bit it goes from zero to
what is it twelve that would be four
thousand so this one goes to one
thousand I think one thousand which
would be the hundred percent okay so
then let's try it so now instead of on
and off it's running it a little bit
slow so let's increase the Duty here
that's 600 I think we go from nine on
and back to zero so now we're able to
control this speed so turning radius
stuff like that I mentioned how how
interrupt handlers are nice to have but
only if you want to interrupt your
executing code in order to read a value
and maybe send it off but there's
something called you said.you async IO
which uses co-routines so this is a
different way of programming where you
set up tasks on async functions and then
you say run these tasks and that the the
functions themselves they yield so it
executes in the in a function and then
it says oh I'm not going to be doing
anything for five seconds come back to
me in five seconds and then there's a I
think is round robin approach where it
goes through all the tasks and that
enables you to run things concurrently
so if we try to go crazy now let's do
the file to let the thing that shows the
text on here let's make a temperature
measurement and what this does is
instantiates the temperature thing and
this one sleeps for one second so this
sleep is a blocking sleep while the you
a sync IO dot sleep is not a blocking
sleep that actually yields to the to the
next task so we're gonna see how that
actually effects we have two little
buzzers here's let's try those as well
we're going to be playing a song and
then eventually there's a killer
function here which it just waits for 20
seconds and then it exits the function
so it works like this you set up an
event loop with you a sang sang kayo you
create the task file to lead you create
the task temp that we looked at
and then we're going to instantiate two
buzzers and try to play the same song so
to see if it actually goes out of sync
or if it runs at the same time which it
should and then at the end on the event
loop we're going to run until run all
the tasks until killer is complete and
on killer takes 20 seconds so since this
is a lot of code the paste mode doesn't
always work but we can try unexpected
end dance so it would be nice if we
could get this presentation to work
again which we can try
print 1 yay it works I don't know if it
remembered all of this or if this is
actually but let's try it let's run it
raaah it worked so if you notice the one
second blocked the entire everything
because it's just stunning there in this
one task waiting
I guess I'm approaching the end but I
would like to try to one last thing I
guess so if we go to one thing we
haven't done yet is that we haven't we
haven't put a main dot pie program in
there so then it can run again
dependently i don't have to put code in
there and for it to run so there is one
called breadboard HTTP server so i'm
going to put on my hotspot now on my
phone and I'm going to be connecting to
this hotspot on the phone and let's put
the file onto the device and what you
can do is that you can try to connect
yourself to as this ID is kubernetes
life line and password is work work so
if you connect to this on your phone to
this Wi-Fi micro Python oh is it called
breadboard
and we're gonna put it and we're gonna
put it as name has a name mean dot PI so
hopefully this will we forgot to put
here good command so we're transferring
a file on to the microcontroller and
what it should be doing now
is after we recycle reset it if we
connect it again - come here if we reset
it so when I boot up the pins are acting
a little bit wonky and the how its set
up with this is that something you know
it goes on if I if I have the toy
connected what's on and on off again
this is off so I need to power my micro
controller and then turn on their tank
and sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't
so what we're going to try to do now is
that we're going to try to run an HTTP
server on this microcontroller and we're
gonna try to drive this thing together
or maybe a reset will do
so if we like something is going on here
so we try to reset it and see what it
does it's disconnected and what is the
reason for that hotspot is on and if we
look at the file so in my boot up pie I
have I made a connect function and in my
main I'm connecting to the Wi-Fi and
then I am setting my the pins that are
connected to the end to the motors on
each side and then I have an HTML here
that I serve using a socket and it's
accepting requests and there are two
simple there's a simple form here or you
can increase or decrease your the duty
on the pin right so I was hoping that we
could see whether or not we would be
able to drive a particular place and we
have 30 seconds left
Oh
does that mean that it works No
maybe
it's connecting it's connected now so
this is the IP address that it's
connected to are we able to connect I
wonder I would also have to connect to
my hotspot
there was another example where we would
be using MQTT and this is a more
reasonable way if you want your devices
to connect to the internet and talk to
each other
send temperature measurements up and
down okay
as anyone able to see you are well I
don't have to be able to yeah I I
haven't turned it off on yet or I
haven't connected but if I connect the
battery so I have a battery here on the
side that means I don't you have to use
this USB and if I carry on darn it or
that maybe someone has turned on
yeah it could be that it was not
supposed to do that but it's worth one
more shot and maybe some electrical
engineer would like to help me out next
time but something's happening now so go
ahead and try to hit this thing hit this
the mushroom see if you guys can do it I
[Music]
think it starts turning at maybe like
500 600 where we're at now
nah anyone for the turn right really
into the turn left oh it's not working
oh but we can't do anything with that
well at least someone here in the
audience is moving one of the motors
which is kind of cool let's give it one
last go and
and
work work is the password I'll show you
uh-huh we have the same issue only one
direction might look that way so since I
don't have a Weber Apple now I'm not
able to see the print output which I
would be able to see if I had their
Weber Apple setup I needed to connect it
to that device in order to defer to do
that
so with that climax I think we're done
I think the tips would be always
document what you're doing don't get too
invested if something is not working
right you have to leave it alone
go back because a lot of times there's
just a miss wiring somewhere and you
just have to distance yourself from the
problem before you come back try to get
started by some microcontrollers they're
really cheap get a laser cutter they
really help to make your project even
look even cooler and have fun thank you